I am so excited.
Her award-winning, groundbreaking podcast,
Dying for Sex has been downloaded 10 million times
and counting.
(audience applauds)
I know.
And now she hosts the brand new podcast, Call Me Curious,
that features hot topics and explores mysteries
out in the world.
She also happens to co-host a podcast
called Straight Talk with Ross Mathews, hello, hi.
Please welcome Nikki Boyer.
Hi.
(audience applauding)
I'm so excited.
Thank you for having me. I love you both.
My two best girls here right at the same desk.
I think we're gonna be both at your wedding
as well.
We will.
So you guys know Drew Barrymore is my flower girl
at the wedding.
I'm his flower girl.
And Nikki is officiating
the wedding.
I am.
I am so honored, I haven't even told anybody yet.
I'm very excited.
'Cause I was with Nikki when I met my fiance Wellie.
How cute is that?
We were on the rooftop of this beautiful hotel
and I had spotted him in the corner and I was like,
hmm, what's going on over there?
And then after you met him, you had a brief moment
and I looked at Ross and I said, you just met your husband.
(Drew gasps)
She did right.
High five. Isn't that so great?
Like I had a feeling, I knew it.
We met back in, what? 2007 I think?
Yeah, this is at the Golden Globes.
This is the day I met Nikki
and she wrapped her leg around me.
Do you see that?
My kinda girl.
Yeah.
I didn't give him a choice
if he was gonna be my friend or not.
I was like, we're doing this.
I like to koala on the eucalyptus tree myself.
(Ross and Nikki laughs)
And so we met on the red carpet
and then it's been 15 years since then.
We've been great friends forever.
We always worked together.
And I will tell you this,
Nikki and I are hosting the Ambie Awards,
which is like the podcast Academy Awards, this year.
Wow.
Very exciting.
Uh-huh.
(audience applauding)
And I dunno if you know this,
but Nikki won Podcast of the Year,
last year for Dying for Sex.
I did. I know, it is such an honor.
I was so blown away by it.
That must've felt good.
It felt amazing. And for many reasons.
Obviously just to be honored for storytelling,
and also the podcast was about something
very, very near and dear to my heart.
So, you're gonna love this.
You, I hope you listen, because it's called Dying for Sex,
and it's about my best friend, Molly.
And she was diagnosed with stage four breast cancer,
so she decided to do something really bold.
So she left her marriage of 15 years
and decided to go on a sexual journey, and finding herself.
So it's not just about sex.
It's about love. It's about friendship.
And it's about finding what you wanna do
with the time you have left.
Wow. I have to admit, setting that tone is extraordinary.
Thank you.
Look at my friends, they're so amazing.
Look at Molly too, right?
Yeah.
Well, speaking of stories, Nikki actually,
would you be kind enough to tell our next story?
I would love to. I'm excited about this story of course.
Everything's wedding related.
Uh-huh.
So if you're thinking of popping the question,
there's a brand new way to do it, my friends.
The New York times reports that people have moved on
from the flash mob to the proposal party.
The proposal party is a secret gathering
of your friends and your family, where your beloved
is under a false pretense
of why they're coming to the party.
And then you surprise 'em with a proposal.
Doesn't that sound fabulous?
Well, um.
No.
Wait. No?
This gives me anxiety.
(Ross laughs)
Why?
Because I've been pressured into things in my life.
And I think when a lot of people are there watching,
you feel obliged-
Oh.
To not let the moment go wrong.
And then before you know it, you might find yourself
in a situation that you are not certain about,
but feel, you know, pressured into,
because there's a whole group of people staring at you.
Oh, that you're gonna say yes
because grandma and aunt Helen are staring at you?
Exactly!
Really?
I never thought, oh God, I never thought about that.
I know!
You're running.
And I, for some reason, I'm only thinking about that.
It makes my head tingle.
You know, I thought kind of differently though.
Okay. Give the devil's advocate.
Well, I just thought like when I proposed to Wellie,
it was the height of the pandemic and we did it on Zoom.
And I surprised, I told him we had a Zoom happy hour
with friends, but I had this one, Nikki Boyer
Navigated it.
She navigated it.
She navigated and hosted the whole thing.
And I have to say before that happened,
I would've rolled my eyes
at something like that.
Yeah.
But then once I got to host the party
and invite the family members in,
and we all got to talk beforehand
and then Wellie and Ross popped up on the screen,
and then it sort of all unfolded so beautifully.
I was like, oh, this is magical.
(audience applauds)
(Ross chuckles)
Thank you.
All right. Next up.
You know, we like to tackle the really important questions
at this desk.
Questions like, are tall, skinny dudes the best cuddlers?
Well, a writer at InStyle investigated this story,
and so many people are hot to trot for tall, noodle men,
like Pete Davidson, Machine Gun Kelly, they like 'em.
And the writer of the article herself
loves a cuddle with a good Gumby-like man.
(Drew and Nikki laugh)
It turns out there is no scientific evidence
that this is true.
Shocking.
I know. But there is science behind cuddling.
It's good for you. It increases your feel-good hormones.
And I know you two are two of the most tactile people
I know.
I'm very affectionate.
Yeah, I touch people that I shouldn't probably touch.
Yeah.
(Ross laughs)
I am way too enthusiastic,
and way too grabby.
Right.
You know who's someone I do know that I like to cuddle?
No.
Who?
My best friend, Chicken!
Oh, come here. Oh!
(adience applauding and cheering)
(Ross laughing)
I love it.
Get in here.
Are we doing? This is happening.
Thank you so much, Nikki Boyer.
Catch the Ambies on March 22nd,
and remember the podcast, Call me Curious.
(bright upbeat theme music)